from the New York Intelligencer Putin de
cries U.S Satanism in bizarre speech
annexing parts of Ukraine did you guys
see this Putin said uh it was kind of
crazy he said that the West Was satanic
and he said that they're doing gender
experiments on children or something to
that effect he he gave a 37-minute
speech in in the middle of Moscow huge
crowds and he said that that the West is
quote sheer Satanism and it's turning
turning away from moral neural norms and
religious values while offering children
sex change operations so is he wrong
he's not wrong but he's but but he's not
an angel himself I know he he he you
know he he brought up a good point let's
be let's be honest and I think he he's
not wrong in some of these instances but
but again that doesn't make him the the
good guy here right I think you know
it's like it reminds me of that I think
something Jack told me about RT or how
he described RT is like RT tells the
truth about us and lies about Russia
whereas our media lies about uh lies
about us and might tell the truth about
Russia right right so it's like it's
like you have to you listen to Russia to
talk about our problems and you're like
yeah that's actually a fairly accurate
description of how our government is
behaving he's got a you know you gotta
watch RT to if you want to learn about
what's going on with protests and
activism this is the funny thing about
how they destroyed the lives of all
these RT uh reporters and personalities
yeah back when um when was it was like a
couple years ago you think it was that's
only 17 or something is when they
started hammering I think it was the 18
maybe no it was recently like Lee camp
for instance yeah you know we've known
him for a long time and like he's not a
Russian agent he's like a regular
American dude and he's like left-leaning
but they they they ban and his podcast
which was unrelated RT simply because he
worked for RT Chris hedges too another
very famous journalist again on the left
also banned and labeled Russian uh
propaganda Abby Martin Abby Martin got a
heart well uh didn't Larry King work for
RTG he did yep so so here's what they so
did Jesse Ventura RT looks for people
who have opinions that are bad for the
West they hire them and let them do
their thing basically funding these kind
of these kinds of narratives I've
recently been coming really disliking
this East-West narrative like it's the
line of demarcation runs through London
are you kidding me like that's not
British Empire crap and now they want to
segment us into one area and say that
Russia and China dude the West is China
West China is west of me right now
that's the West I'm not gonna play this
british-centric game anymore
that was basically the idea right yeah
London yeah they wanted to take control
of The Narrative of who's where on Earth
and say that they're in the middle it's
crazy well they're the ones who have the
the zero the King which is Greenwich
Mean freaking Bank of international
settlements in Switzerland look at that
man and English is spoken basically
everywhere yeah you go to Japan and
there's like the street signs and the
highways are in English and Japanese
colonists man they tried to colonize
China just like they did to India they
tried with the Opium Wars and they
failed and that's a big part of why
there's so much aggression Putin
actually said it is neo-colonialism and
he said this is great he said the West
is racist for spreading russophobia I'm
like okay I don't know what you're
trying to say like what part of the US
is Satanist is it the woke stuff because
that's what you're saying like
they he's he he plays this a similar
game right yeah I don't care which
government some people someone super
Chatters the other day saying like no no
Putin's fighting evil and I'm like okay
no Putin launched an aggressive war and
invaded his neighbor right that's bad
and I think and it starts and it
kick-started all of this right it's not
a defensive War you're right it is a war
of aggression but it's a war of
aggression where your enemy has Rockets
right on the border of the country next
to you so like who's the aggressor right
just it's just it's just I mean two
wrongs don't make a writing this isn't I
mean I don't know I'm sorry like they're
I I've there are situations where in a
seemingly aggressive war is actually
someone responding to acts of War by the
other side I think the classic example
of that is the uh Six Days War
where Israel was you know Egypt put in
place a naval blockade of the Red Sea
and prevented Israel from accessing and
shipping anything out of its Southern
port and so it had if it wanted to ship
anything to Asia to go all the way
around Africa right and that's that's
clearly like act of War violence and so
even though Israel struck first in terms
of like actually military assets
striking other military forces I think
it's pretty clear that that was that was
not an aggressive war in the sense of
they were they were the first wronged
party in terms of work like an act of
war against those yeah this conflict
goes back and forth for many decades now
and and you could Point hey Russia did
this hey NATO did this and and you can
make a legitimate arguments that are
very convincing by by both sides to me
both of them are being idiots people
shouldn't be dying for governments
politicians should be fighting their own
words Wars and shouldn't be sending
innocent people to do it but but you
made a very very good point there uh
talking about The Six Day War being
brought on by of course the stopping of
trade and trade routes and and denying
countries resources it is what usually
Sparks Wars so this is why the the
bursting of this pipeline is so
important because it could be that major
galvanizing event that starts all of
this it's also why turning Ukraine
against Russia in 2014 with that
Revolution whether or not the CIA was
involved or not I hear they were I don't
know but that is you could argue that
that's kind of an active they cut off
their access to the Black Sea like
that's at least a Sebastopol yeah no
that was I mean that was a huge screw up
and I think uh I mean the U.S diplomacy
there was appalling I mean there's no we
had no business overturning that
government like yeah John McCain was
there okay it goes back it goes back
before the Syria for instance Russia's
got a base in Tartus the U.S is
basically aligned against Assad uh the
Assad regime who is aligned with Russia
and every effort we made hurt Russia's
interests in tattoos so of course you
can go back in time as long as you want
to go back in time you will always find
something absolutely absolutely and you
know 2014 John McCain was there the CIA
was there Victoria Newland was there she
was again pushing for a lot of the
protests there and and she did have an
impact and and this is the result of
this that we're seeing here and I I
think Putin was baited into a conflict
and as soon as he sent troops there
um this has escalated to a very severe
level who do you point to for
responsibility I think all of them are
responsible I think all of them were
being stupid and I think all of them
need to stop immediately before they
jeopardize the the human civilization
yeah the liberal economic order does not
need to patrol Russia anymore it's they
all know that the New World Order is
coming that George Bush Senior was
talking about it in the late 80s like
they're ready for it now we need to
transition to a New World Order where
we're not at war with Russia there could
be our most potential greatest Ally it's
really weird no one wins with Wars
politicians bankers and and
multinational corporations win wit Wars
but no one else wins it's ideology and
it's a question of
I would say perhaps it's a bit reductive
but not having access to classify
documents Vladimir Putin does not want
to be subservient to Nato the U.N to the
world economic forum that doesn't mean
he's a good guy it means he's standing
in the band like I ain't doing it and
they're like there's more of us than you
and we're stronger and he's like don't
care try me so there's no he's going to
be our greatest Ally if if uh you know a
communist authoritarian came up to you
in and said work with me to throw people
in a gulag would you do it uh not no I
would say no so I'm not saying that's
what is literally happening between the
two Powers I'm saying there is a line
where you would be like I will never
work with you we will not be allies
because the ideologies are just too
disparate yeah it would be I don't want
to adhere to the world economic forums
laws and sanctions and and give
corporations the ability to sue American
taxpayers if they if we don't buy their
products like that's what the trade the
TPP trans-pacific partnership wanted
with their investors State dispute
settlement Clause that got Trump thank
God overturned I don't want that stuff
either I don't think Putin wants that
crap I think so so we need to build
something better but we're not going to
do it if we're at War but see Russia is
doing this is doing something similar
when they're they're trying to build up
the Russian Trade Federation they
there's been I guess maybe it's a bit
hyperbolic to say but you know Putin
just said today I guess it's maybe I
don't know what the time zone is that
the fall of the Soviet Union was was it
was was terrible and the leaders left
them all the people to just fend for
themselves he has consistently expressed
dismay at the fall of the Soviet Union
and it looks like all of his actions
that he's been doing in terms of
building up this Federation he wanted
Ukraine to join the Russian Trade
Federation he wants to build what the
West is also doing so it's just like
pick your poison I happen to think this
ladies and gentlemen you want the us to
win more importantly we need to win
politically so we can stop the war but
if a war is going to happen you want the
us to win for one simple reason you live
in it and as much as you might really
hate Joe Biden despise his politics
because I certainly don't like the guy
at least you can recognize you share one
thing in common you share a place like
you share like the United States and so
that means as much as Biden might be
selling selling us out and being corrupt
he doesn't want to lose his property
value so even if that means on a scale
of 1 to 100 with 100 being like shared
values and one being like barely any you
have one with Putin you don't have any
Putin some people are are posting things
like oh but he opposes Satanism and the
double no we're not you don't want Putin
to win no Putin is a different kind of
the same bad right of a similar bad he's
another rock in a hard place yeah he's
another politician who's been in power
for how long 22 years many decades who's
looking out for himself and looking out
for his country and his interests and a
counter argument I would make is that no
one's going to win this war if there's a
war no one's winning this one I'm gonna
win you know why because I got chickens
I think I read somewhere for something
pretty insightful which was that you
know we tend to be very annoyed with
like the Biden and the Democrats
hypocrisy when it comes to this stuff
and it's very frustrating and one thing
about Putin is he's not really a
hypocrite he's just sort of Will To
Power you know straightforward like Yes
actually I just want to conquer your
country and I'm going to do that now
rather than sort of like you know miss
you know mixing messages machinations
machinations and so like there's a
tendency for us being super frustrated
with how ridiculous the Democrats
rationalizations can be that we're just
like oh breath of fresh air somebody who
just says what he wants it but you have
to realize like no no no that's actually
you know
that's still that's very very evil and
wrong right like to have this will to
power style of Putin and just conquer
trying to conquer your neighbors but
that's what almost every politician is
essentially if you kind of go down to
the bare minimum of it and uh Putin did
you know it does release a lot of you
know disinformation a lot of propaganda
he does like to confuse people uh he
does uh you know use a lot of different
tactics that the West doesn't usually
deploy
um and I remember seeing I forgot which
documentary this was but it was
describing his strategy of financing his
opponents of creating confusion of of
creating a situation where you weren't
able to fully understand the larger
political ramifications of it but while
everyone is confused and debating he
gets all the power himself I forgot the
documentary that perfectly described
this kind of larger psychological trick
that politicians play on the people
um
I'm going to try to remember as much as
I can that's one yeah I mean that's
that's what possible always do how do
you know a politician's lying he's his
mouth his mouth is moving exactly wait
wait their mouth is moving right
politicians can't be lazy I don't like
this the mouth is moving yeah
politicians aren't people I don't like
that Vladimir has been in power for 22
years that really upsets me because I
think the point of the Russian
Federation was they were creating some
sort of Democratic Republic I don't know
if they consider themselves a republic
if it's just a federation at this point
whatever that means but he stepped out
and he was gone for a little while and
they said his Lackey was running the
show while he was behind the scenes but
then it's like he came back and at that
time I was like well I think what he's
doing is he's afraid that the liberal
economic order the military war machine
is going to take over the world and he
wants to make sure that it doesn't
happen on his watch and until he's
comfortable that the United States is
the good guys again he's going to be
there protecting Russia but I don't that
doesn't justify Wars of aggression I
don't justify that stuff but it and
maybe it's still that is his methodology
like I let someone come into power
they're going to be weaker than me
they're going to capitulate and I can't
let that happen hyper normalization is
the term that I was looking for that
describes what I was just saying it was
a part of a BBC documentary from 2016
and there's a small clip of it that is
absolutely fascinating and explains what
what Putin kind of mastered but I think
is also being practiced here in the west
as well that I think a lot of people
should understand this larger trickery
these larger psychological tricks played
on by politicians against the people uh
hyper normalization is the word of the
day that you should look up filmed I was
going to say look on the search engine
look on the brave search engine
since the 1970s given up on complex real
world and built a smaller fake world run
by corporations and kept stable by
politicians that's the impetus of the
2016 BBC documentary hypernormalization
and that runs parallel with like the
insurance agencies that the attempting
to take over the world medically and
control you know doctors seven minutes
that they get to spend with their
patients instead of the old
doctor-patient relationship you got
pharmaceutical companies and insurance
agencies trying to run things I just
love how we have commercials where it's
like is flourbustron right for you call
your doctor and I'm like no they cause
death like why would I call my doctor be
like I saw a random ad for a drug I have
no idea what it does but they looked
Happy on the commercial yeah it's like I
don't know yeah and then they're friends
with the insurance salesman rep and then
they like the rep they sell the Reps
drug I think it was Lunesta I think it
was remember Lunesta right for you and I
didn't know what it was I'm like there's
a butterfly it's like floating around
what's happening and I guess maybe I was
too young I think Rogaine was the first
one Rogaine Rogaine commercials in like
the 90s and they never said what it was
in the commercials I was like what it's
the only commercial I ever saw where
they never said what it was and they
just show people smiling and I was like
what is this it's like Prozac it's like
I'm assuming whatever it is just makes
you happy yeah imagine if they well it
is kind of funny that there's a lot of
drugs that are basically prescription
drugs derivatives and of methamphetamine
salts or just outright opiates and so
they're basically like we're gonna make
opium and heroin illegal but if you get
a prescription of a different form of it
we're going to put a commercial on and I
don't think they actually do commercials
for that stuff though but they certainly
they crank it out through the
pharmaceutical industry I don't know if
we need American constitutionalism for
the future we could have a global
organization where we don't use the
American Constitution and it's much
different it terrifies me to think that
a corporation would Implement its
function onto top-down governance and
you'd have like you know World economic
forum and Pfizer and Johnson and Johnson
and you know Boeing running everyone's
lives that's like I don't like that that
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there